ich habe mir hier immer noch ein paar
schlappen gegönnt für acht euro kann man
immer gebrauchen also ich muss sagen die
sowohl dies hier finde ich gar nicht mal
so schlecht kostet 110 euro
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video sieht das eigentlich
koloss dieses bin ich so mache bei einem
neuen ich würde es jetzt nur noch zwei
einem neuen bio konto koloss im jahr
heute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich habe heute eine kleine sache vor ich
habe genau diese idee schon länger in
meinen ideen für videos stehen
das hat diesmal bereit krass aber ich
habe es heute leider irgendwie nie
umgesetzt brauchen auch immer keine art
na ja wir machen uns heute erst
wahrscheinlich habe ich schon gelesen es
geht um 100 euro im prime markt wo es
100 euro bei gucci ich muss sagen bei
drei mal war ich einmal in meinem leben
da war ich 14 oder so und bei gucci war
ich auch einmal da war ich schon ein
bisschen älter ich habe eigentlich nur
noch einen coolen t shirt als
geburtstagsgeschenk gesucht nachdem ich
das am fahrradweg 1 unter 1000 euro
haben bin ich direkt wieder raus gerannt
naja und guti muss ich keinem erzählen
premiumsegment wirklich das teuerste vom
teuersten und mir ist jetzt eigentlich
nichts billiges eingefangen als primark
bevor wir dazu kommen ich muss erstmal
auf die airports verlosen ich wollte das
eigentlich im nächsten video machen die
person von mir entscheidet was ich kaufe
aber das ist jetzt schon so ewig her
deswegen hier haben wir die airports die
ich vor und war drei wochen ist es
bestimmt schon härter und ist auf der
pulli von snipes der ja auch irgendwann
verlost wurde das löse ich auf jeden
fall doch auch auf jeden fall irgendwie
heute um die airports wert die airports
gewonnen ich bleibe euch hier den
gewinner kommentar ein herzlichen
glückwunsch du hast gewonnen' entweder
du hast schon nachricht von mir oder
schreibt mir einfach über instagram
viel spaß damit ich hoffe ihr seid nicht
allzu traurig wenn ihr nicht gewonnen
hat aber ich sag mal so unter der
bedingung dass wir heute was cooles
erkaufen können kann auf jeden fall sein
dass sich das am ende auch wieder
verlosen werden ich muss sagen heute ist
wirklich extrem heiß wir haben 30 grad
aber ich mache auf jeden fall dieses
video auf jeden fall bevor es losgeht
wollte ich noch mal so ein bisschen
meine idee erklären
und zwar wie schon eben kurz erwähnt
primark ist ja ein billigladen also da
gibt es klamotten was weiß ich was die
noch haben alles ist wirklich sehr
günstig stammt jetzt auch nicht aus dem
westen produktionsstätten sowie man ja
eigentlich weiß halt ist ja kein
geheimnis
deswegen bin ich da auch eigentlich nie
gut hingegen weiß ich nicht ob da die
produktionsbedingungen besser sind
keinen plan aber es ist halt war
wahrscheinlich ungefähr 100 fach so
teuer
ich weiß nicht um heute mal so ein
bisschen diese extrem krassen
unterschiede zwischen diesen
billigsegment und diesem luxussegment zu
vergleichen habe ich gedacht du bis zu
200 euro gibt's da 100 aus und da 100
aus falls es bei gott überhaupt
irgendwas kriege für unter 100 euro ich
habe absolut keine ahnung ich hab mir
nämlich gedacht das könnte echt
interessant werden da kann man auch
vielleicht ein kleines format haus
machen wenn ihr die idee bleibt dass man
noch nach oben da und dann will ich
eigentlich auch gar nicht lange gefallen
sind die stadt erste trailer dann zu gut
dann nehme ich euch mit ja
heute ist es so fucking war schon
angekommen in der stadt jetzt geht es
erstmal zu prime und ich bin mal
gespannt was ich dort alles bekomme ich
glaube es wird ultra viel sein also
wirklich das tut mir schon ein bisschen
weh da hinzugehen und einfach so viele
sachen mitzunehmen für so wenig geld ich
weiß noch früher so mit 14 habe ich da
glaube ich mal weil sie nicht da da habe
ich von meinen eltern 80 euro bekommen
und konnte shoppen gehen und habe mir
bei primark extrem viele sachen geholt
und da habe ich mich super drüber
gefreut heutzutage ist es irgendwie
alles ein bisschen anders und ich hab da
auch einen anderen blick drauf also ich
bin wirklich mal gespannt was sie heute
für mich haben und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns dann gleich im primark der
irgendwo dahinten ist das ding ist ja
auch immer diese diese primer geschäfte
die gehen so über drei etagen und dann
hat man da so diese leute die damit so
richtig fetten taschen rausgehen also
das sieht man ja eigentlich in jeder
großstadt die kombinierte wein so
da waren wir sehen 45 euro nehme ich
will jetzt nicht so faul sondern im
aufzug nehmen hier diese fetten tüten
meine ich also das ding ist echt extrem
fed ein t shirt habe ich schon und die
salat hat er ist extrem leute gehen alle
nicht mit der treppe sondern auch hier
drei euro wir haben uns ins keiner haben
will dass die feier ich sage heute ich
habe mich immer noch ein paar schlappen
gegönnt für acht euro kann man immer
gebrauchen also ich muss sagen diese
oldies hier finde ich gar nicht mal so
schlecht kostet 110 euro habe ich mal
diesen blauen hier genommen hier gibt es
auf jeden fall ein paar schuhe
ich finde gar nicht mehr so schlecht die
kosten also 120 euro schweiß nicht also
davon nehme ich alles mit hatte hier
haben wir jogginghosen für sechs euro
wie soll ich mir auch eine menge leute
die tüte ist jetzt eigentlich schon so
halb voll und ich würde sagen ich bin
jetzt sogar 60 euro oder so keine ahnung
würd ich würde sagen ich melde mich wenn
ich wieder draußen den kaugummis sind
auch immer gut so leute das ist die tüte
dies ist sinnvoll alles sachen die ich
gekauft habe
ich bin ehrlich zu euch ich dachte
eigentlich ich war von dem 200 euro und
das heißt hier drin ist hat 73 euro
gekostet während ich also für 100 euro
kann sich eigentlich noch nach
ein drittel davon da zu wecken so leute
die man vielleicht mal die dritte
dimension der tüte erkennen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht doch nicht
also ich bin jetzt wieder zurück im auto
und dann keine ahnung eigentlich muss
ich sogar sagen also ich habe insgesamt
jetzt ja um die 15 bis 20 sachen gekauft
würde ich mal schätzen und was mich
eigentlich überrascht hat das hatte ich
gar nicht mehr so im kopf also viele
sachen da waren die fand ich auch gar
nicht mal schlecht also vom design her
und so kann man das schon einige sachen
auf jeden fall gut tragen ich habe mir
ein paar sachen mitgenommen die ich auf
jeden fall für mich selber verwenden
werde na ja wir machen uns jetzt auf dem
weg zu gucci und schauen mal was wir
dort für das geld kriegen ich bin
wirklich gespannt ich habe absolut keine
ahnung wenn es schlecht läuft kann ich
auch gar nichts kann halt wirklich sein
und danach muss ich erstmal duschen weil
ich bin so hat am schwitzen alter wir
haben in köln heute 31 grad
alles klar leute also in köln ist genau
darin irgendwo gut
ich denke es war mein handy mit ob ich
das denn eine ahnung weil wenn ich da
drin filme ich glaube das wollen die
nicht also da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher deswegen wollen wir auch gar
nicht erst versuchen nachher pflege ich
raus oder so handy ist voll in ordnung
also ich bin gespannt was es gibt und ja
gleich ich bin ein bisschen nervös und
ich hallo meine direkte frage haben sie
irgendwas für unter 100 euro
die nehme ich die kosten 90
das war heute gesagt sagen japan ja
danke die meisten sind so indirekte
lassen egal wie das suchen und viel
dafür machen wir ein geschenk überreicht
worden sind kleine tüte oder so haben
okay schlicht einfach geschmacklos genau
heute halte ich schäme mich ja nur dann
wirklich ein bisschen ich habe gerade 90
euro für kinder ausgezogen ist sorgt das
wollte ich nicht ohne spaß hätte ich
diese sollten bei primark gekauft die
hände nicht mal euro gekostet so um
diese sorten muss ich mich jetzt ob
leute eine sache muss ich aber sagen
letztes mal wo ich dort war hatte ich
irgendwie so ein bisschen schlecht
erfahrung mit dem verkäufer also
irgendwie hat er mich dann voll
herabwürdigen behandelt sag ich mal
heute waren die echt korrekt also mega
nette verkäufer aber auch richtig lustig
so geht das nicht immer so weil die
meisten tun hast du als würden sie
irgendwas teures kaufen und dann kaufen
die nichts das haben die mir so indirekt
damit erzählt und anstatt dass man dann
sagt ihr hier ich habe nur 100 euro zur
verfügung was habt ihr dafür tag socken
ja die wollte schon immer haben 90 euro
besorgen
so leute wieder zu hause
ich glaube dass hier sagt alles ja wir
haben hier einmal die treiber tüte die
komplett vollzogen hin und auf der
anderen seite die gucci tüte die möbel
ja so zu einem zehntel ausgefüllt ist er
also ich bin wirklich glaube ich der
letzte der solche socken tragen würde
ohne spaß deswegen weil es ja von euch
sagten so gut schießen die wollte ich
immer schon mal haben kommentar
schreiben mit eurem instagram account
oder irgendwo ich erreichen kann
abonnenten vom kanal und irgendwann wird
dann auch die sich seine verlosung
aufgelöst weil ohne spaß ich kann solche
sorgen
ganzen glaube ich kümmerte ich bin
wieder zu hause und ich muss euch jetzt
auch mal zeigen was ich alles gekauft
habe damit man auch so einen kleinen
vergleich hat also bei manchen sachen
war ich wirklich so krass verwundert zum
beispiel dieses shirt hier ja größe mds
von 16 euro auf 3 euro runtergesetzt
drei euro für ein schwätzchen hier kann
man es noch mal sehen was mit den ganzen
sachen passiert erkläre ich euch
vielleicht noch hier haben wir ein t
shirt für 10 euro was ich selber
behalten möchte und zwar ist das der
nacht kündigt von game of thrones meiner
lieblingsserie
deswegen habe ich es gekauft zehn euro
für ein t shirt ist für mich in ordnung
so dass hier fand ich eigentlich auch
ganz neues ich glaube da kann man ein
gutes instagram tode mitmachen konnten
auf jeden fall bei instagram da ist die
alle knie hat neun euro kostet hier
haben wieso badeschlappen für acht euro
habe ich mir ein rudi geholt in blau für
zehn euro größe l feiert eigentlich also
ein weißes t-shirt das ist glaube ich
für frauen kommt auch mclaren tiefer ist
als dann haben wir noch dieses sport
shirt für fünf euro
genau für fünf euro die qualität ist
miserabel also wenn ich das hier so
anfasse noch ein t shirt für sieben euro
einfach so basic weiß auch intel kann
ich eigentlich auch selber weil hier
immer noch in jogginghose für
unschlagbare sechs euro und dann auch
dieses teilen und thatcher für ebenfalls
drei euro parlament habe ich auch noch
bestimmungen für 150 und noch drei
weitere teams aber das ist jetzt
eigentlich scheißegal ich will da gar
nicht zu lange das eingehen zwei sachen
davon bald ich selber den rest bringt zu
tafel oder so also ich habe dann einen
guten kontakt und da freuen sich
bestimmt leute drüber klar ist und jetzt
nicht die besten klamotten arbeitnehmer
in klamotten und leute und jetzt kommen
wir hier zu diesen socken alter sack
also auf jeden fall sehr hochwertig
verpackt tüte in klein so eine tüte
hatte ich noch nie und das mussten wir
einfach nicht anfassen
klar ich könnte jetzt anziehen nur ich
denke mir doch wirklich die kann ruhig
einer von euch haben ich habe sowas
nicht ich bin mir zu 100 prozent sicher
die qualität ist dies gut klar aber die
ist genauso wie adidas oder nike
soziales fühlt sich jetzt nicht
besonders krass an und das ist wirklich
menschen gibt die für socken 90 euro
bezahlen und dann damit rum rennen ja
keine ahnung also selbst wenn man noch
so viel geld hat das eigentlich zum
fenster rausschmeißen kann wie man will
ich kann es einfach nicht verstehen
warum man sich dann sorgten für 90 euro
kauft dann kann man diese 19 euro doch
einfach irgendwem anlass geben der ist
vielleicht ein bisschen nötig hat und
davon keine socken kaufen also diesen
vergleich man sich auf jeden fall noch
zeigen kommen hier ist die gucci tüte
dann schwenkt man rüber und hat hier die
ecke von der prima tüte boom
und wie schon gesagt die güte die ist
eigentlich lehrer schreibt man sehr
gerne euren wagen dazu in die kommentare
das war's mit dem video laster nach oben
dafür noch ein paar abonniert mich auf
youtube und gerne auf instagram da ist
alex w und wir sehen uns haut rein